the best most effective commercials
leave a lasting impression on the
consumer but sometimes brands take
things too far which brings even more
attention to the commercial and thus the
brand encouraging envelope-pushing in
the industry here are a few examples of
banned commercial spots from across the
globe bar gets bad Israeli supermodel
bar FLE has starred in two commercials
deemed too steamy for primetime in a
home country one for clothing company
hoodies in 2016 is basically a Sports
Illustrated Swimsuit Issue spread come
to life but the original cut lingered
too long on bars behind and implied she
was bottomless at one point so it was
censored by Israel's version of the FCC
but even the censored version was too
much the timely spots still couldn't air
until after 10:00 p.m. this wasn't the
first time a bar starring spot got
barred from primetime in 2014 she
co-starred in another hoodies commercial
with a mustachioed muppet and two other
versions of herself which was said to
have too many sexual insinuations you
just can't get enough of me huh giving
up the gun in 2005 Microsoft cooked up a
commercial day knew would cause a
commotion
so they effectively pre banned it in the
US allowing only a limited audience of
hardcore gamers to see it
the playful Xbox 360 spot featuring
strangers engaging in a sprawling finger
gun shootout in the middle of the busy
terminal never aired on television was
only shown at promotional events
[Applause]
once the ad leaked the internet
speculated wildly about why the spot
wasn't given a wider release leading to
rumours about network or FCC bans over
its violent content but it was simply
Microsoft thinking outside the Xbox no
apologies in a weird twist in 2014 a
SodaStream Super Bowl spot featuring
Scarlett Johansson about what it takes
for a video to go viral ended up going
viral but for an entirely different
reason than the one depicted in the
video the spot showcases how easy it is
to use the device to create a soda
that's better for the consumer and for
the environment but then ScarJo decides
then stripping down to a slinky dress
and sipping on a soda seductively as
what's needed to achieve viral stardom
sorry how can absolutely
oh yeah she done ironically the ploy
wasn't even given a chance to work since
Fox rejected the spot over the mocking
apology to SodaStream competitors but
the controversy drew millions of
eyeballs to the uncensored spot with the
offending line as well as the otherwise
identical scented spot during the big
game
sorry Coke and Pepsi dead to rights this
2001 Dutch commercial for the Hyundai
Veloster featured the personification of
death itself coming to claim a soul and
the shockingly brutal way death gets it
done ouch it's a good thing that the
velocity' only has three doors a
death-defying safety feature meant to
cut down on such accidents interestingly
the spooky spot was actually shot down
by Hyundai itself before airing for
being too shocking for their brand but
like a lot of these banned ads it lives
on in infamy Trap House speaking of
disturbing violent images how about this
shocking 2006 commercial from New
Zealand for the Toyota rav4 the car is
so amazing apparently that it turns
husband and wife against each other in
their
had quest to drive it they set
cartoonishly home alone style traps to
try to slow the other down while they go
through their morning routine viewers
complained it set an inappropriate
message to children was not socially
responsible and it would encourage
similar behavior so the popular ad was
yanked from the airwaves for heaven's
sake this slick 2011 acts excite spot
features skimpily dressed angels falling
from heaven and giving up their
immortality to hook up with the dude
that wears a spray-on deodorant the
supposedly sacrilegious TV spot was
banned by South Africa's Advertising
Standards Authority for offending
members of the Christian faith a move
that surely increased the number of
curious Christians watching the spot
online as a devil of a predicament for
senses indecent exposure
in 2007 Bud Light created a cheeky
commercial featuring a carefree couple
tossing off their clothes and going
skinny-dipping assuming they're alone
oops the spot was supposed to air during
this Super Bowl that year but was
rejected by CBS the ban however led to
even more exposure for Budweiser since
it made headlines generating tens of
millions of views online and giving it a
much longer shelf life like being
featured in videos like this one 10
years later thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all these
cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]